it's the little it's you know getting
out of the
shower and the towels around your waist
and you're looking at yourself in the
mirror and you're just like
there i am elliot page is opening up
about his quote
tears of joy after coming out as trans
this is your first television interview
as a trans man
elliott page in the trailer for the
oprah conversation
airing april 30th the oscar-nominated
actor gets emotional
all the trauma aside that it took you to
get here
the courage that it took you to stand
within the truth of yourself and to do
the thing
that you've always known you needed to
do
what part of your transition has
actually brought you
the most joy
goodness what has brought me the most
joy
the most joy
it's the little it's you know getting
out of the
shower and the towels around your waist
and you're looking at yourself in the
mirror and you're just like
there i am the upcoming interview
follows elliot's announcement in
december
and by every indication the conversation
will be a celebration of his journey so
far
and i'm not having the moment where i'm
panicked
i'm not having all these little moments
that used to be
just being in a t-shirt um
it's it's being able to
touch my chest and um
feel comfortable in my body for the
probably the first time
tears of joy in march the umbrella
academy star became the first
transgender man to be featured solo
on the cover of time magazine and the
oprah interview appears to be elliott's
latest move and shining a light
on issues affecting the trans community
what do you want to say to those who
don't
seem to think trans children dying
matters
in an interview with vanity fair elliott
opened up about his decision to sit down
with the talk show host
he calls the anti-trans rhetoric in our
culture quote
devastating and points to the recent
wave of controversial laws and bill
proposals
which have been criticized for targeting
transgender youth
eliot said talking to oprah felt like an
opportunity to use a wide reaching
platform to speak from my heart
about some of my experience and the
resources i've been able to access
whether therapy or surgery that have
allowed me to be alive
to live my life
[Music]